je vous présente rabab rabab c'est mon
éléphant rose personnel et ça veut dire
babar à l'envers je suis en train de
commencer tranquillement l'emménagement
dans le bureau mais c'est pas le propos
de la journée nous sommes en pleine
semaine spéciale micro expressions et
n'oubliez pas que dans la description il
y a un lien vers la playlist qui
regroupe toutes ces vidéos il ya
également un lien vers le livre de paul
ekman qui m'a beaucoup inspiré pour
écrire ces vidéos nous avons vu la
colère la surprise aujourd'hui on va
passer au début
le dégoût à ne pas confondre avec le
mépris est une émotion très puissant est
de fait très dur à contrôler également
et c'est pour ça que j'ai invité nos
âmes bonsoir
tu vas trop j'ai lu cette phrase voulait
être dégoûté regarder la chaîne de chico
90 quand même un code aujourd'hui c'est
différent on va - collaborer ensemble on
va surtout regarder les expressions de
son visage par rapport au dégoût parce
que tu avais fait une série de vidéos où
tu mangeais des trucs chelous voilà les
1,7 à ses raisins secs toile alors on va
se référer à ce souvenir là pour
regarder sur ton visage de ce qui se
passe et après moi je vous en parle à
côté la micro expressions qui est elle
même liée au dégoût est un signe de
roger compilation de la personne qui est
en face de nous soit de ce qu'elle est
en train de dire soit d'un aliment qu'on
a en face de nous ou alors même d'une
situation on la déguste et je crois
quatre trucs
ouais il y avait un cinquième c'était
des grillons et que je n'ai pas montré à
la caméra passe était dégueulasse
les signes majeurs qui caractérise le
dégoût sur les narines qui remonte un
peu un peu comme ça un peu comme dans
les vampires dans buffy
peut-être qu'ils étaient juste dégoûté
par du centre on ne sait pas les muscles
pyramidaux qui se contracte en français
ça donne les sourcils qui froncent comme
dans la colère ouais c'est vraiment des
yeux une contraction au niveau du menton
via le muscle de la houppe qui le voit
ma coupe
et bien sûr la lèvre supérieure qui se
relève un petit peu ne vous attendez pas
à voir ça comme ça ça se relève mais un
outil peu risqué intéressant c'est de
voir que l'un des muscles qui sert à une
autre micro expressions sert aussi à
celles ci on y reviendra lundi dans les
commentaires d'un d'autres vous d'eux
m'a demandé quel intérêt on avait à voir
les micro-expressions en fait qu'un
intérêt à voir que quelqu'un était en
colère si ce n'est que pour lui dire
qu'il est en colère la question en soi
n'est pas stupide
elle devient même très intéressante si
on élargit et les l'intérêt de voir une
micro expressions vous allez voir la
vraie émotion des personnes à qui vous
parlez ce qui ne correspond pas
forcément à l'aspect social que l'on se
donne un petit peu comme un masque qu'on
mettrait au dessus de ses vraies
émotions vous connaîtrez donc plus
facilement la pensée réelle d'une
personne ça permet de détecter un
mensonge ça permet de détecter une chose
qui est caché en tous les cas d'avoir
une vérité émotionnelle
imaginons que je raconte à quelqu'un que
je postule dans la même boîte que lui là
où il travaille un poste similaire et
que lui me répondent d'un c'est génial
on va être collègues mais qu'à cet
instant précis je vois passer le micro
expressions de colère
ça va me permettre de faire une
supposition attention pas une vérité une
simple supposition on n'a jamais une
vérité sur à celle ci l'hypothèse est
donc qu'il n'apprécie pas que j'aille
postuler dans la même boîte que ça les
nerfs alors peut-être parce qu'il a peur
que je prenne sa place ou simplement
parce qu'il ne souhaite pas que j'aille
là-bas et que je voit certaines choses
ou que je parle à certaines personnes
je peux donc désamorcer la suite par
précaution par exemple en lui disant
c'est super gentil parce que moi à ta
place ça n'aurait pas forcément plu donc
je préfère venir tant parlé avant
d'entamer les vrais démarche dis moi
franchement si ça te gêne en quoi que ce
soit et je comprendrais vraiment au
cours de cette semaine vous est proposé
tous les jours de vous concentrer sur
des points clés et des gardes et du coin
de l'oeil quand les muscles faciaux
bougeront sur un karl de secondes vous
le verrez vous y serez plus sensibles
avant d'analyser il faut pouvoir
détecter et c'est aussi le but de cette
série pour continuer en insérant le
dégoût ayez donc conscience du visage de
l'autre et garder un oeil sur les lèvres
pincement ouverture levée de la lèvre
supérieure
les sourcils en entier pour la colère le
daeu ou pour l' étonnement les narines
pour la dilatation et la remontée les
yeux pour les quarts qui ment et
aujourd'hui on rajoute donc le menton on
est toujours dans cette zone dans ce
petit rectangle
merci beaucoup à chico nono qui est
passé à paris il est passé pendant un
café et donc gelé monopolisé lui aussi
pour faire quelques exemples merci
beaucoup
regardez cette vidéo pensez al ahly
qu'est ce qui vous a plu
c'est important est allé voir les vidéos
vraiment du mange des insectes je vous
mettrai aussi le lien en ficher dans la
description savent elles commencent à
vivre
elle s'appelle dégustation d'insectes je
crois n'oubliez pas de vous abonner au
mental blog le défi du mental veulent
c'est une vidéo par jour du 1er janvier
au 31 décembre
rendez vous demain à 17 heures ciao
ça
là